the body of George Floyd whose death at
the hands of police opened up a global
flood of anguish arrives in South
Carolina greeted by lines of family
friends and strangers it was in
Fayetteville 46 years ago that he
started his life but it ended in
Minneapolis where he went searching for
a new one
[Music]
mourners in masks paid tribute to the
man they knew as a gentle giant with an
infectious smile this was the second
memorial for George Floyd who in death
has changed the course of a nation
just like the coronavirus police
brutality has yet to find a cure it is a
difficult time for us all and we must
all come together and come to the
frontlines to protect each other the
outrage on the streets hasn't stopped in
Washington huge crowds protested against
racial injustice and police brutality
[Applause]
the White House is beginning to look
like a fortress under siege videos of
police tactics are only serving to
amplify calls for more accountability in
Minneapolis they've banned chokehold and
they're signs of a cultural shift to the
NFL now says it should have supported
players kneeling during the national
anthem
we the National Football League admit we
were wrong for not listening to NFL
players earlier and encourage all to
speak out and peacefully protest the
president hasn't changed his mind though
still insisting the act is disrespectful
and unpatriotic
[Applause]
public health officials are warning
about the risk of protests spreading
coronavirus but the desire for change
appears to have eclipsed the fear of
getting sick
Bedelia Lynch Steiners Washington